you want to prove that you can speak in
the voice of the characters contributing
in the writer's room not
not just sort of sitting there having a
bad day a lot of this job is attitude
what really excited me was the idea of
going against that grain going against
the mold so to speak of television and
creating a character who was by his very
definition
designed to change my personal
philosophy is
if it's a coincidence that's ultimately
bad for the main character
then it's then it's then it's kosher
then it's acceptable
if it's a coincidence that's good for
for that person for that protagonist
then then it's lazy someone
like us uh who for whatever reason
actually did such a thing actually
decided to to cook meth
and because i was thinking instead i was
thinking you know why
why would someone like me or tom
decide to do that and then i thought
well you know you gotta you must need
money
and and one thing led to another and by
the time the phone call was over
uh that that moment of inspiration had
had led to
uh didn't have a name for him yet but
led to that character who would
eventually be known as walter white
[Music]
and before that in about 2004
i was talking to a buddy of mine a guy
named tom schnauz who's one of our
writer producer directors on better call
saul and on and
previously on breaking bad and around
about 2004 we'd been out of work for two
years
x-files have been off the air since
about 2002 and we're on the phone
just bemoaning the fact that we we
couldn't find another writing job
uh that that was i was about to say that
was near as good as the x-files we
couldn't find a writing job at all
it was kind of lean slim pickings uh at
that point
and i said you know what are we gonna do
now and he said
why don't we get a winnebago a caravan i
guess
in australia why don't we get a caravan
and uh
you know put a meth lab in the back of
it and ride around america and see the
sites and cook meth make some money
so this is a documentary
what was interesting is that in the
moment he made that joke
uh this sort of little eureka moment hit
me
uh because i'm a very boring
law-abiding guy and and he is too
despite his sense of humor
and it it dawned on me as he was making
this joke that would be an interesting
character to write about someone like us
uh who for whatever reason actually
did such a thing actually decided to to
cook meth and uh
because i was thinking instead i was
thinking you know why why would
someone like me or tom decide to do that
and then i thought well you know you
gotta you gotta
you must need money and and one thing
led to another and by the time the phone
call was over
uh that that moment of inspiration had
had led to
uh i didn't have a name for him yet but
led to that character who would
eventually be known as walter white
and that's very rare having that kind of
uh you know for the writers in the
audience i don't know how it is for you
folks but
in writing is is hard work and and you
got to really
you know keep your keep your uh pencil
to the grindstone so to speak and but
every now and then when that
inspiration hits that's a wonderful
thing um in terms of believability
uh how do you write a show like breaking
bad which revolves
a lot around coincidence like uh
characters meeting in certain places
and still keep it believable there were
there were some there were some
there were some bitcoin there were a
couple of big moments of coincidence
uh the biggest one probably would you
say i'm gonna guess
would you say is when walt sat down at
the bar next to g yeah that was a big
moment
and we talked a lot about that and my
personal philosophy on that
and i think some of these guys said
that's that's kind of a big coincidence
isn't it
my personal philosophy is if it's a
coincidence that's ultimately bad
for the main character then it's then
it's then it's kosher then it's
acceptable
if it's a coincidence that's good for
for that person for that protagonist
then then it's lazy but in that case
it in in in short-term fashion it
wound up moving walt's uh
machinations a little further along but
it also stole a big
it led to him killing or allowing he
didn't kill her but he allowed
jane to die in the next scene jane
jesse's girlfriend
and therefore he lost a big chunk of his
soul we talked a lot about that about
what yeah coincidences i just i was
intrigued
at the idea of taking a a good man
uh good you know the protagonist the the
good guy
and turning them into that was the part
i left out in this pitch what really
interested me
aside from this character you know why
would he do this thing and whatnot was
it dawned on me that television of which
i am a giant fan
historically exists uh tv shows
exist uh in a kind of a stasis world you
know when you watch
uh bart simpson for 30 years now on on
the simpsons he never grows up he never
becomes a different character than he is
uh all the great tv shows uh in history
uh
it it's it it's helpful for the
characters to not change because if they
were to change
you know you don't have that comfort of
inviting them into your room week week
upon week and
not knowing what you're going to get
it's better for marshall dillon to stay
marshall dillon for 20 years on gun
smoke and whatnot and
what really excited me and this i think
came a bit later than that phone call
with my buddy
what really excited me was the idea of
going against that
grain going against the mold so to speak
of television and
creating a character who was by his very
definition designed to change
uh and of course when you have a
character who changes when that's your
by design that's what your tv show is it
it therefore becomes a finite
tv show instead of uh well there's no
infinite tv show but you want a tv show
that can go on typically you want one
that can go on indefinitely
hence the the stasis that you you seek
but i i figured you know i'm kind of
lazy i don't want a show to go on 20
years if i get that lucky that's too
much work
let's do a finite tv show the good guy's
going to turn into the bad guy and then
and then it's all over so the kind of
stuff we did on the x-files was the hard
work the heavy lifting
of of the job was we would sit in front
of a cork board three feet by five feet
with a big thing of thumbtacks and a big
thing of index cards and a whole bunch
of sharpie
magic markers and we'd sit there and say
okay what's the teaser what you know
what
what's we know we're doing an episode
about aztec mummies
so what's a teaser you know what's
what's a really scary t and you build it
brick by brick you know
each card represents a a a plot beat
not necessarily a scene but you know
three or four six
eight cards might represent one scene
but each one of those
cards is some indispensable plot beat
of that scene and and you you break the
story
you build it in other words brick by
brick index card by index card
and and put it up there you know i
wanted you know and it and and by the
end of it you filled up this entire
three foot by five foot
cork board with a teaser and and and the
the four act structure that we would do
in the x-files which we also do in
breaking bad teaser act
i guess it's five acts if you count the
teaser teaser act one act two act three
act four
and this whole this whole three foot by
five foot board is filled with
pinned up index cards by the time you're
done most episodes of breaking bad
are like a math formula they're like a
math problem
and i always wondered if there was a
really great faulty towers episode where
they admitted like we started
with the last scene and wrote backwards
like how did
how did he get how did basil faulty get
to this scene and i and so i watch a lot
of breaking bad episodes and there's the
math formula
where they get into some really
stressful predicament the kind where
you're like
[ __ ] come on you know and then not only
do they get
out of it but it's believable and it's
the only way they could have gotten out
of it
and that to me seems like are are you
starting at the beginning and writing to
that point are you fi are you getting
to are you starting at the end and then
going backwards and and kind of
backtracking to get them out of it
we did a little bit of everything in the
five or six years were
five years were doing this we did a
little bit of everything i'm so glad
that it felt that way
uh i can i can i can tell you for a fact
none of us in the writers room
especially me were any kind of
mathematical geniuses
so i was doing an interview uh before we
got out here a young lady was asking
you know uh when with a couple times
you know what can you name sometimes you
wrote yourselves into into a real corner
and uh the biggest one of all is walt
buys this machine gun
uh at this at the beginning of the 16th
toronto 16 epis final
16 episodes we had no friggin clue what
he was buying the machine gun for
really and it was so in hindsight it was
so
stupid but i just thought it'd be cool
hey buys a machine gun
i we always what and then
we'll figure it out later we'll figure
it out oh my god
we really did i'm not actually proud of
that um
i we would give all these ponderous
interviews over the years to places like
the writer's guild magazine or whatnot
we believe in organic storytelling which
which stems from
flows from character does not flow from
plot and and by the way i
i really do believe in organic
storytelling but every now and then we
just go
batshit and we'd put a machine gun in a
trunk or the other time was you know
walt jessie are in the rv and hank is uh
is is got him in the junkyard dead scene
i was thinking of
that was one of the two i mentioned yeah
yeah yeah so you really went through a
detailed pitch of the pilot yeah
yeah and then obviously you must have
talked about where it was going from
there did you have the full five-year
plan in your head or no not at all i
i i pitched in great detail as i say
that first episode
and and i hope that that would hook
these these potential buyers
and luckily it did and then when they
said where's it go from there i i would
say
i would get very general at that point
but i would say something that that we
did abide by for the whole six years i
would say
this is a show about process it's a show
about transformation it's a show about a
guy willfully
transforming himself from who he used to
be to what he will become
and what he will become if you give me
the time to do it
and i can't tell you right now how many
years i think it should be but i
what i want to do with this show is i
want to take this mr chip's character
and have him turn himself into into
scarface
and it was it was it was that general
that was the pithy one-line sentence
that i've
probably said like balloons should drop
for the sailing it's probably the
millionth time
but uh but it's it's that old cliche
about it's good to have this one
sentence pitch that people remember and
i
i i have to say this this one this one
helped me out a great deal this was a
good
one sentence pitch for this show and we
and we
stuck by that uh self-imposed franchise
we
that's that's what that's what the show
was thinking about your experiences in
the writers room what is it that you
think
makes for a good staff writer this could
sound terrible but i don't know how else
to put it
you really want to write in in the voice
of the show it's not a time and a place
at least at the beginning of your of
your being hired it's not really
the optimal time and place for you to
express lots of individuality
you really want to you want to prove
that you can
speak in the voice of the characters
contributing in the writer's room not
not just sort of sitting there
having a bad a lot of this job is
attitude if you're not already this
person pretend to be but be someone that
people want to spend 10 11 12 hours at a
stretch
with yeah one of the most important
things in a tv writer's room is just
it's just to keep the conversation going
come up with dumb i'd not be afraid to
come up with what you know
is potentially a dumb idea because the
dumb ideas
i've seen it more times than i can count
very often lead to the good idea and
once you started as a teenager to write
you know essays for school and stories
but were they always
people who've read your people who've
come across your stuff said i read this
script from me and i thought wow
it's just on another level to what
people do was your writing always
of quality i i don't think so i
[Laughter]
i uh i think if you if you start with an
enthusiasm towards something uh you you
probably i mean i think i started off
just uh writing this piss poorly as
anyone but uh i think that uh uh you
know
try and try again you you keep you keep
doing you keep at it you keep hammering
away at it i i don't think
my writing was anything special for for
a great many years
uh but but i i love doing it and i did
it to the exclusion of of many other
things that uh
would have made me a more well-rounded
person perhaps
but um about selling the show how do you
sell a show
like this to a network you know you just
um well i can i i i seem to hesitate
i hesitate when you ask because i don't
know how you do it except
put like you do everything else put one
foot in front of the other come up with
something in this case that you really
believe i really believed in this
and then go and uh pitch it as best you
can and let the chips fall
where they may people are either going
to buy it or they're not i
i seem to be at that early stage as i
said earlier i was i was worried
perhaps too much about walt remaining
sympathetic and so
i i arrayed against him his
brother-in-law who was
by design everything that walt was not
and he's kind of a hail fellow well-met
frat boy kind of a as you say he's kind
of an [ __ ]
jock and and it and it makes it
even more painful for walt that walt's
own son seems to gravitate more toward
his
his fire pissing uncle than he does the
old man you know
and um but once once i got to know dean
norris who
who plays hank i started to realize how
complex
an individual he is and how interesting
and how talented and multifaceted he is
and some of those
and my writers did as well and some of
those complexities and facets
uh made their way to the writing of the
character and and the character became
less of a
less of a jerk and more of a interesting
uh
well-rounded individual that's that's
what i love about this process
of television production you you
you roll with the punches sometimes your
job is is taking lemons and turning them
into lemonade you know sometimes actors
suddenly become unavailable sometimes
like at one point the house jesse
pinkman lived in got sold out from under
us and we could no longer shoot there
you have to roll with these punches but
but sometimes they make the show better
you